but a semi apologized that I keep doing
this because it feels a bit current
affairs even for me but I just can't
pass up this opportunity this graph that
you're having a look at right now is a
graph that the world has been watching
for the last three months and this is
actually some reasonably at this point
old historical data you can see it ends
in late February because this part of
the world was kind of ahead of the curve
quite literally speaking and compared
the receiver on Guangdong is the largest
province in China it's the New South
Wales of China if you like except for
the fact that it's got more than the
population of Australia in it by a
significant factor these are the actual
in blue reported cases of covered 19
recorded in this region that they
published for the world and that the
whu-oh was watching so very carefully
that's what the blue numbers are an
actual you know record of this is how
many people we've got in hospitals and
all the rest anyone want to suggest what
those red lines are they're not actual
data there's something else anyone want
to take a stab no I a projection it's a
model and in particular and I'd love you
to write this down because we will come
back to this later it's a particular
kind of model it's called a logistic
function that's a fancy sounding name
it's fancy and different to what you've
heard of before because it's not like
graphs that were used to graphing think
about the last two weeks and what we
have a look at in their topic we looked
at polynomials we looked at absolute
value we looked at we didn't look at
trig functions actually but then we
looked at Exponential's and logs
remember that now we know what
Exponential's are like they sort of get
faster and faster and faster
we don't logs are like they get slower
and slower and slower but this this is
kind of um well if i zoom back out it's
kind of like the red child of an
exponential and a log function can you
see why have a look at the beginning you
can see it sort of starts off quite
shallow yeah
and then it starts to pick up pace
that's a pick up pace and then at some
particular point it starts to slow down
again
okay now I have a question for you and
it's got two parts why does it do that
why does
so slower like the number of cases why
does it increase but it's not very fast
to begin with this is just a practical
question it is in your thoughts max okay
okay so so at the beginning right we've
got small numbers of people who have
this disease so they can't spread it to
many people yeah but as you get more 4/9
etc they have the capacity to spread
further people travel all the rest so
that's why it picks up pace right so
this is the sort of exponential part of
the graph as it were okay but then at a
certain point things the trend changes
right
and there are still we're getting more
and more cases they're never going to
decrease they're only gonna increase
this is total normal it's cumulative but
it starts to slow down anyone want to
tell me why this happens it's a
different reason
altogether why is it slow someone else
have I think this is been happening all
around the world we're hoping this is
what happens right Sophie right okay so
we kind of um all watch this number
skyrocketing and we all collectively
panic a little bit because high numbers
actually make us sit up and pay
attention
also things like the interventions we
put in place like social distancing
shutting things down
all them take a while to actually take
effect right and then suddenly hopefully
we hope that things actually slow down
and that's what this logistic model sort
of captures that at a certain point it
goes from this exponential version of
things to a logarithmic version of
things at least we hope okay now here's
the thing I want to get across to you
right what are we looking at so far
we're building it's stationary points
which come from like how do you find a
stationary point what informational
knowledge do we use to find stationary
points we use do an T X the first
derivative and set it equal to zero now
I want you to have a look at this other
edge stationary points on this
particular curve have a look
then if the answer is no there are no
stationary points because it's moving
all the time there's always increase it
might be slow it might be fast but it's
always increasing okay so there are no
stationary points and we have language
actually to explain why I want you to
think back to Tuesday's lesson
Tuesday's lesson we talked about
positive ingredients negative gradients
and when you've got zero greens
coming through we said we had weird
language versus technical language right
we said it was increasing if the grade
it was positive and you can look and you
can see it's always increasing do you
agree with that monotonically increasing
was the fancy word we used okay so in
this case like where it switches over
I'm gonna and maybe on your graph if
you've done a rough version of this okay
I want you to find the spot on your
graph where it sort of switches over
from that exponential behavior to that
logarithmic behavior it'll be somewhere
in the middle I mean on mine I'd
estimated somewhere around let's pick a
being fair color somewhere around here
is my estimate if you just had a look at
the part to the left it looks pretty
exponential and then a part to the right
it's pretty logarithmic do agree I'm not
looking for a change that the derivative
will tell me I'm looking for how's the
derivative changing right it's always
increasing but are you increasing first
or are you increasing slow that's the
question I'm asking for okay now to move
this out of the way so I can write some
stuff